it's interesting because very few people
even really deny nobody what cat saying
is true which is the most bizarre thing
about all of it I would have thought
some of y'all be like no no I got
receipts it turns out Cat Williams has
decided to bring Kevin Hart's ex-wife on
tour with
him I didn't believe it when I saw it I
still if you aren't aware Cat Williams
and uh Kevin har or beefing they have
been for quite some
time Cat Williams feels like he's an
industry plant already had his deals
when he got here have we heard of a
comedian that came to LA and in his
first year in La he had his own sitcom
on network television and had his own
movie called soul playe that he was
leading no we've never heard of that
before that person or sense that person
what do you think a plant is Kevin Hart
feels like he's a hard worker and that
Cat Williams is a bit of a lazy bum who
squandered a lot of his opportunity get
Force for a long time some people got
them Kings him taking his ex-wife on
tour that's wild that's wild but it is
what it is what what's funny though is
that uh Tori kept Kevin Hart's said name
I when when artists do that I think it's
weird I think it's weird but whatever I
get it you mean after the divorce you
didn't go back after the divorce you
don't go back to it's weird to me I'm
going to be a heart until I decide not
to be that's weird he doesn't mind her
having it and her kids want her to keep
it too and that's fine I get that I I
still think it's weird and then I'm
going to be a heart I'm going to be a
heart until I decide not to so now
you're a heart that goes on to her with
cat that's that's yeah that's what
you're doing that's what you're doing
that's that's what you're doing yeah
that that's what you're you're going to
be a heart until you decide not and now
you as a
heart H you decide to
go well to be fair I'm pretty confident
that when he left after he cheated on
her I understand all that I just is a
bit W but then again then
again then then again everybody's cool
with the name it's just the name thing
the namee keeping thing everybody's cool
then I don't have no business not being
cool with it it's not of my business
right after that uh she goes to tour
with cat she sees an opportunity she
sees it cat's being pity it is going to
be what it is going to be yeah Petty she
could be funny so who knows on that
front uh but that's
I think it's really just messing up with
her because when she goes on toour her
with cat and Cat said I only bring
people that are more funnier than me on
T if you're not funny and she can't it
really can be a demise it if she is
funny then do you booo all day there's
ever an audience that's going to eat up
whatever she got to say about her
ex-husband is it not Cat Williams
audience I mean just saying I'm just
saying that's like me bringing on fresh
and fit's biggest hater on tour with us
to
open I'm just saying so listen all this
talk I've seen a lot of people respond I
have never seen celebrities respond to
so much
podcast like they have to this one I'm
talking about everyone coming out the
woodwork you got ludicrous rappid yeah
never been Illuminati only udti and I
only left with when coming from
any party now I'm married with kids the
evolution of life never been a clout
taser never say for likes R John
Singleton you never have to flex when
you earn every one of your Fast and
Furious checks afro with The Sideburns
yeah that's my signature addics on the
rise comedians check your
temperature I'm like bro what are you
doing what are you doing Cat Williams
said something about you joining the
Illuminati and
what do you say Luda had to do so there
was a Crossroads where we were both
invited to an Illuminati thing and it
had to be one or the other of us and
decisions had to be made so it was both
of us we were equal one of us had to cut
off all their hair and couldn't do the
Sideburn thing no more with the points
and the next person they said was going
to get $200 million because they were
going to pay him 10 million of movie to
do 20 movies and that's how the
conversation happened one of those
persons turned out to be ludicrous and
the other person turned out to be Cat
Williams now one person ended up with a
light-skinned ugly faed wife that's
never done a remember I told you that if
I say that it apply to seven people it's
part of what they give you okay I didn't
get it all right it was some sus so
some something about booty and
everything else yeah okay Luda came out
with a a rap a rap I was like
what is going on these people are weird
you got Steve Harvey talking about and I
ain't got to address my haters and all
these clips are servicing but it's
interesting because very few people even
really deny nobody C say is true which
is the most bizarre thing about all of I
would have thought some of y'all be like
no no I got receipts nobody the only
thing that you guys are denying the only
thing that you guys are denying is he
can't run that fast and didn't read that
many books the rest you're not saying
that's weird Hey listen him
not being able to run a uh a 40 yard
dash in under 4 seconds or whatever the
it was under five and and he did
he's 52 and I think he ran it in like 5
Seconds which is 467 which is still
incredibly impressive for his age he
could have ran it in six people were
like ah but he lied you see he didn't
run in the exact I was like who cares
that's a 52y old man running that fast
like I was actually shocked when he ran
I'm not going to lie I saw him running
and I'm like like damn crack got a
really not not saying but like it just
gave me that Vibe but see you you see
old crackheads just moving with purpose
that's what it felt like some of you 26
year olds can can run that fast stop
facts stop facts but moving past that
it's just seeing the response to the
interview I don't think I've ever seen
like it anything like it I think in it
of itself it is very singular to me in
my mind and I think it's probably the
second most viewed podcast ever though
number one being Joe Rogan's podcast uh
which I think has 56 during Co at some
point he in one interview he was able to
Skyrock at to that like say what you
want that man is charismatic he knows
how to tell stories I'm Sor and he knows
how to run interviews I watched that
thing from start to finish and it was
amazing everything you the only thing
you try to say against cat is that he
can't read that many books and he don't
run that fast
mhm that's it that's it out of two hours
and something things something seconds
and something minutes that he said that
he was talking the only two things that
you so here here here comes the second
part now what comes after this does
anything change no no nothing changes
it's going to settle down after two
weeks everybody going to look at Steve
Harvey a little bit funny and stuff like
that white people are still going to
love him he's still going to have his
shows everything not much is going to
change although for cat the whole new
respect is born and he's going to be
able to tour and do his thing but for
the rest of them that got called out is
going to be like man Cedric is go ahead
I think it did irreparable damage to
some of their legacies Cedric in
particular I think was really hurt by it
sure I think Steve Harvard much less so
cuz he has a more Global audience sure I
think it's skyrocketed cat into a new
level yep and I think overall as far as
the Hollywood stuff goes or all this
other talk I don't think it really
changed the legacy of most of the people
involved in any any strong way I think
it's one of those things where people
learn more information they learn about
the industry so maybe for a lot of
people who unaware before they get more
info but beyond that I don't think it
really changes much that's my honest
assessment it heard it heard said and
Ricky Smiley the most the rest y even
Kevin Hart Kevin Hart is not going to
change no it's not going to it's going
to bug him it's going to Hitch him yeah
but other than that MoneyWise or
globally it's not goingon to change much
nope lud Chris is gonna show up in the
next Fast and Furious right because he
gave up his booty for it and everybody
else going to keep on doing what they do
so that's my h sucess